yeah I want to bring up some really
underappreciated factors in the
relationship to treating the thyroid
especially hypothyroidism with Synthroid
or some other synthetic hormones you
know unfortunately this is not a
short-term
treatment it's a long-term treatment and
so you're taking this hormone like what
are the side effects are there any side
effects other than the total dependency
on this hormone that you're taking but
there's another side effect that I want
to talk about that you probably are not
aware of when someone takes Synthroid
over a period of time especially if it's
post-menopausal there's a higher risk of
getting bone loss or osteoporosis or
even osteopenia so the question is why
and how that relates to maybe a better
option so this video mainly relates to
those people who want to continue to do
conventional care they don't want to do
Alternative Care and or they're already
on Synthroid okay this is a really
important video for those people you
know a lot of times when you get hormone
therapy whether it's estrogen therapy or
even thyroid therapy you're given this
one hormone but I have an interesting
question
if you're getting treatment for the
thyroid okay with one hormone
and the thyroid produces more than one
hormone
what's happening with these other
hormones or let's say for example you
get a thyroidectomy the complete thyroid
removed right and then they treat it
with one hormone which is T4 so what
about the other hormones what about T3
what about T2 what about T1 that's right
and what about calcitonin right
calcitonin is another hormone in your
body and guess what it's produced by the
thyroid gland so if you had your thyroid
removed or you have hypothyroidism
what's happening with that hormone where
is it coming from and why isn't your
doctor giving it to you well they might
say well we don't really understand that
hormone it doesn't seem to be a problem
but let's just take a look at what it
does okay so you can understand that it
does create problems if you're if you're
not taking it so calcitonin has
everything to do with regulating calcium
it works with another gland called the
parathyroid hormone produced by the
parathyroid which is connected to the
thyroid you have four of them two in the
top two in the bottom so both the
thyroid and the parathyroid work
together to help balance mainly calcium
but also other things like phosphorus
and even to a lesser degree magnesium so
what calcitonin does is it inhibits
the breakdown of bone okay there's
certain cells in the bone that are
called osteoclasts and they break down
bone to release calcium into the
bloodstream whereas the parathyroid
hormone will increase calcium it helps
to mobilize calcium from the bone so you
you can see this teeter-totter effect
between these two glands well what
happens when you have your thyroid
removed or your parathyroid removed
either one and here's the problem when
they take out the thyroid how do you
preserve the parathyroid without
damaging them you must have to either
leave some pieces in there or sometimes
maybe just remove the whole thing I
don't know but these parathyroid glands
are very delicate and they're connected
to the thyroid so many times when you
remove one thing the other is affected
anyhow if you have your thyroid
extracted or the parathyroid you're now
at risk for bone loss okay whether it's
osteopenia osteoporosis and now you know
why because you just removed the two two
key hormones that help regulate calcium
now there's another kind of ignored
syndrome that there's not a lot of
information about but it's called Hungry
bone syndrome where the bone just starts
absorbing all this calcium leaving the
blood extremely low in calcium and this
occurs when you either have your thyroid
removed or especially when you have your
parathyroid removed so now we have this
other problem we have low calcium in the
blood okay here are the symptoms and you
should just know this if you have these
symptoms this could be why you know you
just don't have enough of these hormones
that regulate calcium so you might have
numbness around the mouth or even in the
extremities hands and feet also muscle
spasms tetany twitching in your muscles
and various cramps maybe that wake you
up in the middle of the night and you
have certain bleeding or bruising
because calcium is also involved in the
clotting factors and without enough
calcium it's hard to clot but also
realize you might be low in phosphorus
which affects your energy and your
ability to make ATP which is the energy
Reserve in the body as well as a lowered
amount of magnesium so these are just
things that you should know about going
into
surgery for your thyroid or if you have
hypothyroidism and you're getting
treated or you're on Synthroid they even
have a treatment it's giving someone
calcitonin from salmon for
osteoporosis too much calcium in the
blood is called hypercalcemia because
calcitonin helps lower calcium and it's
even used as a treatment for spinal
stenosis which happens to be like a
buildup of calcium in the spinal cord
causing pain things like that so I think
it's really important to understand that
these glands make more than one hormone
and if you're going to get treated
with Synthroid for some reason I would
bring up
the argument for taking Armor Thyroid it
comes from a natural source an animal
Source but at least armor has T4 T3 T2
T1 and calcitonin it was what they used
before they developed Synthroid it might
be more difficult for the doctor to
regulate but it contains all these
hormones so why wouldn't you want to
take that or at least maybe take both I
don't know but you can work that out
with your doctor but the point is when
someone says that well we don't do that
anymore you better have a good reason
for it like for example it's not going
to create any problems well show them
the references down in the description
of this video of the higher risk for
getting osteoporosis maybe they're just
not aware of it I just wanted to put
this information on your radar and I
think it's really relevant to talk about
the deeper causes of the thyroid as well
and I put that information in this video
right here